okay let's get into this week's audience
questions now the first question I'll
tell you what the question is and then
I'm gonna sort of give a caveat before I
answer it the question is hey David do
you think it makes sense to raise kids
gender and sex orientation neutral so
that they aren't influenced in any way
as to what they want to be or who they
want to be I'm going to answer this
question as if it's like an in good
faith question but it also sort of feels
like a straw man in the sense that there
are increasingly arguments being made
against positions that nobody really
holds or that significant portions of
the population don't actually hold and
this is sort of one of them that comes
from the anti-lgbt sort of transphobic
wing of the political spectrum so I'm
gonna pretend that this is a real
question which is listen some people are
gay lesbian bisexual some people end up
choosing to live their life in line with
the gender identity that they feel is
actually correct which may not match the
physical sex that they were born into um
and since that applies to some portion
of the population should parents raise
children in a completely gender-neutral
and sexual orientation neutral way the
answer is no okay I mean listen let's
see it looks at sort of just look at it
empirically most people are heterosexual
and most people end up feeling as though
they were born into a body that has the
right genitalia that is the right sex
and gender that it is a match that their
identity is a match with the body into
which they were born so there's no real
empirical basis upon which we should say
the logical path forward is for parents
to sort of shelter their kids from the
fact that they are treating them if they
were born with male genitalia as if
their gender identity for life is going
to be male or the same with
with female genitalia there is no reason
why parents should raise their children
with sort of complete neutrality in
terms of behavior about that because
statistically speaking for the most part
if you treat a child born with male
genitalia as having male gender identity
or a child born with female genitalia as
having female gender identity that's
going to be the way that their life
shakes out so
I don't think there's really any
sensible reason why we should say
parents should raise their children
pretending that it's just as likely that
they would end up if they were born with
male sex organs wanting to live as a
female rather than male because the
statistics simply don't bear it out not
even close
what I think does make sense is to as a
general sort of practice of parenting
not hide from your kids that there are a
variety of sexual orientations that
transgender is a thing you don't have to
use those terms necessarily since the
the terms don't make that much sense the
little kids but you can explain that
people have feel different ways
sometimes or whatever language makes
sense it's not really for me to come up
with exactly what the language would be
but the point is you want to foster an
environment where your kids are going to
number one be respectful and treat other
people who are members of the LGBTQ
community with respect and with decency
and the way everybody sort of deserves
and to be treated and should be treated
but also in the event that your child
ultimately expresses these feelings or
has these feelings internally that they
are going to be comfortable telling you
that that's the case that they are going
to be comfortable living as who they
ultimately turn out to be so for me it's
really a straw man to say if some people
are going to ultimately say that their
gender expression doesn't match their
birth sex or some people are going to
end up saying well actually I'm
I'm physically attracted to other men or
whatever that every parent now needs to
sort of raise their children insulated
from a sort of sort of but interacting
with them as if we are placing on them
what the most likely sexual orientation
or gender is that's a straw man I've not
actually heard anyone seriously make
that argument I'm not saying it doesn't
exist everything exists some people are
making any argument you can imagine
basically but let's just be parents who
are raising children that are going to
number one exists in the world treating
everybody with respect and kindness and
number two not feeling as though they
are unable to or scared of or unwilling
to tell their parents what it is that's
going on with them so if you're asking
the question honestly
then that's my answer if you're asking
the question and bad faith then I
probably shouldn't have taken five five
minutes to answer it but I'm going to
assume that the question was being asked
in good faith